I mean I think the most effective use of
the spectacle is brother Barack Obama
himself that he's such a masterful
televisual figure that he can appear on
television late-night shows 5 morning
shows I have the kind of steadiness and
sturdiness that does not really get at
the degree to which the White House has
not really stepped forward when it comes
to this health care bill and standing up
for public option not showing the kind
of backbone sitting back trying to
negotiate here testing here testing
there so you're not giving people a
sense of not just what it is but where
they themselves are headed because they
want to cut a deal rather than take a
stand and of course politicians are
known for cutting deals when it comes to
issues of life and death if you're
Lincoln if you're FDR you're not just
cutting deals Lincoln just wasn't just
cutting deals FDR was not just cutting
deals when it came to protecting the
rights of collective bargaining for
workers and so forth he had to cut
against the grain and take a stand and I
think that the spectacle allows you to
avoid taking the stand
showing backbone see that's what
statesmanship is that's what leadership
is the difference between a thermostat
and a thermometer
I think we draw a distinction between
the symbolic and the substantial issue
assemble and substance that we cannot
deny the unprecedented progress when it
comes to breaking glass ceilings
it could be skipped gates at Harvard it
could be President Barack Obama in the
White House
it could be dick Parsons we can go on
and on but to break the glass the glass
ceiling ought not to lead us to overlook
so many locked into the basement locked
into the middle levels and those issues
of structural their institutional so
when you're dealing with increasing
wealth inequality you're dealing with a
weakening working class and expanding
poor working class and weak poor working
class then you've got some structural
transformations that are taking place in
which there's unprecedented
opportunities at the top from White
House to Harvard to even Princeton
myself and yet you've got these
dilapidated houses you got decrepit
school systems you've got unavailable
health care unavailable child care
depression like levels of
underemployment and unemployment so
you've got this imbalance that it's hard
to keep track of especially in corporate
media you see so that on the one hand
you want to say thank God that Age of
Obama has begun the age of Reagan is
over the greed running amuck especially
at the top is over the indifference to
the poor is being calling the question
we hope and then the politics of fear
has ended so the question becomes okay
in face of the greed will there be
serious talk about fairness in face of
the indifference will there be serious
talk about compassion especially for the
poor and working-class and in face of
the fear of course is hope hope hope
hope hope that's big that's the mantra
right now and it's a good thing that the
age of a bomb is over I put in 65 events
for my dear brother he knew I was going
to be a Socratic and critical supporter
I've always felt that he's not
progressive enough I always felt he
didn't have enough backbone I've always
felt that he didn't draw lines in the
sand the way he should but he is who he
is
and he's a
Astra for a very charismatic politician
I want him to be a statesman that focus
on poor and working people he's still a
politician very much in the Neel Clinton
night mode economic team recycle
clintonites foreign policy team recycle
clintonites and so there's no real
history of a focus on poor and working
people domestically or no serious focus
on trying to seriously focus on poor
people and working people in you know
the Middle East and weird I just tell my
Palestinians Israelis been working class
and poor Israelis working class and poor
Palestinians both of the form are
suffering even though one is under
occupation and one is not so that those
are the kind of perspectives that for me
are very important in this age of Obama